This is an algorithm, although this is maybe up for debate. And when it works,
it makes a doorway. You might have felt like my instructions were ambiguous.
I'm going to pretend they were perfect, though. If you can write clearer
instructions, post them on the forum. I'd like to read them. And now, I'm going
to do my best impersonation of a robot and follow this algorithm. So, first I'm
going to place an 8 by 2 block horizontally. I'll do it this way, so you can
see what I'm doing. And I'm going to stick a 2 by 2 block on the top of the
left end of the 8 by 2 block, so right here. Now, 3 times, I'm going to stick a
2 by 2 block on top of the previous block. So, this was the previous block,
one, two three. And now, I'm going to stick a two by two block on top of the
right end of the 8 by 2 block. And I'll repeat three times, putting a 2 by 2
block on top of the previous block. And now, I put an 8 by 2 block on the
highest two. And we have a doorway.